hello and welcome to the corridor
digital podcast once again we're back
Nico and I sit down here today with WWE
superstar Xavier woods also known as
Austin Creed he's a wonderful person and
he is a huge nerd we had a ton of fun
talking about everything from video
games to anime to wrestling and we also
talked about more deeper things like how
to take control of your own life and the
things that he's done that have brought
him success in doing just that so sit
back relax and enjoy an interesting
conversation because it's about to get
started here on the corridor digital
podcast so did you get into final
fantasy xiv like right when it came out
when it's kind of janky or did you wait
for like the patches for them to fix it
so I wasn't MMO in the moguy at all
that's pretty much because my room one
of my roommates in college actually
dropped out of college or senior year
because World of Warcraft consumed him
like he couldn't do in all things in
moderation situation he cut class told
his teachers that he had pneumonia he
his girlfriend broke up with him because
he's just locked himself in his room and
played wow and like we couldn't we
couldn't understand it and we just came
home one day and there was a note like
hey guys I had to leave because I was
like failing out I was on like academic
probation for so what are you doing so I
was like I don't know I can't do this
because I'm very addicted when it comes
to certain games and stuff and so anyway
um one of my friends had played eleven
it was like oh this is it and like I I
can't I have had memories of animos and
then Final Fantasy 14 dropped on ps4 I
was like okay well I'm in a game hole
right now I need to play and it's like a
free 30-day trial like let me just see
and then within like I don't know three
days I realize that a bunch of people
that I knew played and I was like oh no
that's like well here's my $15 a month
or whatever it is and it's been I guess
so since it dropped on ps4 I played so I
guess I played consecutively for maybe
maybe a year year and a half and then
kind of take a break and then like some
of the expansions came out just recently
in the past like month or so gotten back
into it but it's one of those things
like once you're in like I've been
playing pretty much
like five six hours a week and that's
like on top of like all the other stuff
they're doing so like I'll take like two
or three nights and be like okay not
sleeping tonight because I'm fine I like
last night yes 100% so last night the
blue made stuff dropped and so I'm doing
a lot of stuff a lot more stuff on
Twitch now so what's a twitch channel
this is a chance my twitch channel is
twitch.tv slash Austin Creed which is
different from my YouTube channel which
is up up down down so that is
technically under my WWE umbrella of
things that I like to create while I'm
there and that's which is just kind of
another thing on the side which
donations are being taken because I'm
trying to create a video game studio so
I'm going to create mobile games and so
money that comes from anything that you
haven't got which were those donation
subscriptions whatever goes right into
the fund for the video game studio can
you share any of your ideas for games on
here yeah yeah definitely so the biggest
idea that we have so if you played the
robber Smackdown games back in the day
like 2006 2007 there was a thing called
GM mode so where you were the general
manager of the show so you didn't
actually play the matches you just you
drafted your roster then you book the
shows against someone else booking the
shows and so I used to live with one of
the other guys on the roster named Tyler
breeze and randomly one day when I
hooked up my stuff he's like oh it's my
friend versus rock 2006 and I was like
yeah I really love GM mode and he's like
oh my god me too but this was in like I
don't know maybe 2013 2014 so we would
just play at the house and we loved it
and so fast forward to with the YouTube
channel we've been going for two and a
half three years and I was like you know
what we should play GM mode on the
channel he's like no one's gonna watch
that I was like yeah I know it'll be
really fun for us and now at this point
we're like six eight months deep and
like people love it
really yeah so and it's just it's not
since because it's mainly us arguing
with each other and he's currently
winning right now very much upsets me
but what I want to grow to is having a
general manager game essentially so it's
kind of like like the same ideas like
where's the friends like you take your
turn send you for notifications their
turn
yeah I just go back and forth booking
the show you can send like messages and
like videos to each other like oh I'm
gonna crush you this Weekly
that but since W such a large
organization they do a lot of stuff in a
house they do mostly everything in house
and so I feel like I'm kind of I'm the
bridge between like wrestling and gaming
for for deput of Yui and so what I want
to do is create these mobile games and
take the WWE license and like the names
and the looks and everything that other
outside sources can't use and make these
games so obviously GM mode so that's a
wrestling based game but then I want to
take those likenesses and personalities
that people already know and love or
hate whichever one and make games that
have nothing to do with wrestling so we
take a final fantasy type game so it's
like our Final Fantasy 15 expansion and
now you can play with LexA mojo on your
team looks like yeah but he's not
talking about anything wrestling he's
not doing wrestling stuff like you just
there's his face in his likeness you
know what I mean yeah and so I feel like
if I can kind of break through that
barrier of getting that to start going
then maybe it'll open up WWE to more
more types of games especially in the
eSports realm yeah we have a wrestling
game but it's not it's not an eSports
game it's more like a wrestling
simulation and I'm looking for like a
wrestling arcade game like the ones on
64 been through the day yeah like
everybody loved those yeah and I will
ramble so just just cut me off and ask a
different question cuz I'll just I'll
just keep going well I got a question
for you like your colleagues are they
are they as in the video games as you
are you like this one outlier like
everybody else is like practicing for
the show and getting ready and you're
like just off in the corner on your
switch like what's what's the balance
here I'll know everybody's in yeah
pretty much everybody's in everybody's
got something going on
it used to be cards so people used to
play rummy all the time and now it's
just changed from cards to video games
and there are days where you walk in the
locker room and it looks like an arcade
so yeah it I'd say so before me there
was a guy Sheldon Benjamin and he was
the one who would bring video games
around and then it kind of went away and
then I showed up on the roster and I was
like I need to be playing something so
like at the time I had like a Microsoft
Surface and I just had steam running on
it and I don't play like the old-school
like Tales RPGs and like okay here's
something and then I got a games case
and would bring that around off and
people sort of playing Madden and I was
like oh this is how I get people in ok
here we go
people into like Street Fighter and now
everybody's like deep and attackin we
just really we've had low Majin come to
smackdown he's like the third best
Tekken player in the world he got third
and Evo last year so it's cool because
like everyone was excited that this guy
from the fighting him community was
coming to Smackdown backstage to play
Tekken with us and so it seems like such
an obscure fighting game to get into
everybody we love it rusts like it's
like dar favorite fighting him it's so
good I used to get lost in that game
yeah yeah it's so fun and then like the
bowling like there's so many fun things
to do but yeah everybody everybody
pretty much loves them whether they like
sports games or fighting games strategy
games like what have you I think that
I'm I'm just the one who I know this is
out there like trying to meld the worlds
the most but everybody's playing games
yeah that's interesting what are your
top five games at the moment o top 5
games I actually so top 5 lists are very
important to me so I have it might know
that my phone that I just turned off I
have my top 5 like songs my top 5 games
but like I'll shuffle them so I can
answer these questions um what's the
order so it dub more er double dash is
my favorite game of all time okay
Gamecube I don't know why they haven't
remade that they remaster all this other
stuff yeah we can't get another double
down and then second is nights into
dreams on Sega Saturn third is this game
called mischief-makers 964 yeah and then
fourth is river city ransom and regular
Tendo game and then Mega Man 5 okay so a
lot of like retro games on there yeah
which is like because I feel like with
how fun those games are plus the
nostalgia on them like it's hard to it's
hard to beat that stuff but I am there
is one creeping in that's like came out
last year it's called Elektra knots oh
yeah yeah
it's so good if you don't know Elektra
knots to have you have you played it now
okay so you you've played it it is so
you're essentially a DJ and so like they
have all these songs that are excuse me
there are actual songs but you get to
kind of replace what goes where so they
have like all of the notes and you can
kind of just play along and then you can
record your little riff then you add
another one atom at it and you add the
vocals at the base so you're just
recreating this music and it's like I
don't know like you said you got lost
and taking like I get lost in that
because
Alvie yard and so you're just in this
world and this music is playing and it's
just like super chill and there's no
there's no objective it's just it's just
to play around kind of like a sandbox
kind of music yeah game and that's that
outside it's number six okay here we go
creeping in that's good okay that's a
good let's really good less thanks man
that's one - won't everybody that like
me is that weird like is that weird
playing a video game that you're in oh
hey is that really surreal oh yeah the
first time that you like see yourself in
the game it's like wait I don't have to
create myself these moves some developer
had to do it oh yeah it's like wow they
come you come in and there's like they
put you in this little room with all
these cameras around and they take
pictures of you from like every angle so
they can try to have everything as as
accurate as can be but yeah it's really
cool but oddly enough now that I'm in
the game I don't play with my simply I
don't really ask myself yeah definitely
playing with myself yeah I don't don't
play as myself nah I'm in the game it's
weird why is that uh I think because
when I would make myself in these games
I made what little kid Austin thought he
was going to be in wrestling and that's
more fun to me because it's like a
fantasy thing as well if I played myself
in the game like well I do that in real
life it's like I I got that kind I know
how that guy works
I'm this guy over here hmm yeah that was
one of my favorite things about the some
of the n64 wrestling games is creating
your own character and yeah man my my
parents didn't let us have video game
consoles when we were growing oh no but
they used to they used to go out of town
and like for a weekend or whatever and
they'd rent one for us and my brother
literally did not leave the TV like the
whole time just play the game literally
like they'd leave we'd turn it on and
then they'd come back and we'd close up
put it back in the boxes that was it so
I know what you're saying about is that
the because of what blockbuster or less
yeah yeah yeah
mm-hmm yeah I just saw someone had a
like the rental box for a Virtual Boy
really looks like this is insane for
those of you who don't know Blockbuster
was a place where you have to go to rent
video games or VHS tapes as we used to
call them back in the days of physical
media yeah yeah you know bringing up
this uh playing as herself in a video
gamers and not playing yourself brings
up a topic that actually Jake wanted to
talk about that I think will be really
fascinating which is talking about
personas creating a persona being that
persona creating a new persona being
that persona it's very unique skill to
have and it's one that you clearly
possess you know you have Xavier woods
you have Xavier Creed you have Austen
woods you have yourself also beneath all
this you make some niko yourself right
yeah so when you're creating personas
howdy
where does that come from you know I
noticed that you have a background in
psychology and in philosophy even and so
where does that come from and how does
it you know do you ever feel like there
isn't a blend between persona and real
life or is um so for me I feel like I've
gotten pretty lucky with it so as
opposed to like let's say someone like
like the Undertaker yeah like he's not
really dead not a disconnect but like in
his real life like he's not gonna be
walking around with like this sweet like
deathly armor and like these purple
gloves and yeah and tombstoning you to
hell as we're like Xavier woods a new
day who talks about video games and
loves video games and legitimately plays
trombone and loves unicorns like if you
play trombone oh yeah I think I've been
played for mode since I was in sixth
grade okay
but on TV you only get a couple of notes
I want a full concert they're gonna come
above some money
[Laughter]
I've been lucky especially like with
Kofi and II we just literally been
ourselves and so something that you get
to old a lot in wrestling it's like the
best gimmicks quote unquote insider
baseball the best characters come from
when it's you turned up to 11 if you can
take whatever thing about your
personality that you enjoy that you know
will come through a camera when people
are watching like you crank that up as
hard as you can and that's what's gonna
sell right because lots of us I mean we
obviously go through all the gamut of
emotions happiness sadness what-have-you
but when you can take that and amplify
it to the point where you're not just
feeling it but other people are feeling
it and not feeling it for you they're
feeling it themselves like that's when
you've really tapped into where you're
gonna become successful I think and
sports entertainment pro wrestling but
yet with new day we're just we're
literally ourselves so there's there's
really like not a lot of time where you
have to like turn it off because it's
like you can't you can't turn yourself
off because that makes sense
we're just loud and obnoxious and I
remember the first time I saw you guys I
was like wow so ridiculous you guys had
taken it so far that I had to love it
you know man like I think you guys came
out in a cereal box oh yeah videos
cereal box came out of cereal box with
Saiyan armor on yeah so it was like it's
the whole thing of what we do is to try
to make it what would we like if we
weren't wrestling we're still fans were
coming to the shows what would we want
to see right now in our 30s
yeah we would make us laugh when we
would entertain us well we all grew up
in that era of like Stone Cold Steve
Austin and the rock and everybody's like
a badass you know so like that's kind of
the archetype that we all saw like oh I
want to beat these guys so on the show
now we ran into the problem of like
there's like 30 40 dudes who want to be
badass and it's like well it's a Ross at
three hours show Smackdown just two
hours and NXT is two hours and then
there's like a pay-per-view on Sunday
which is like anywhere between like four
and nineteen hours right so you have to
figure out what if everyone is doing the
same thing it's not gonna be
interesting to the fans once you get
deeper into the show so like what can we
do that's DIF like well in real life I'm
I'm not like a super tough guy um I just
want to play video games and like I
obably know a lot about unicorns and I
really like King Arthur and into Turtles
like how can we incorporate that it's
like and then we had new day I think
it's more of a um it's more like a
breath of fresh air for people that when
we first started doing because it's like
okay cool here's a break in some of the
stuff that we've been seeing lately and
I think that since that started there's
been a lot more variety on the show not
saying that we were the ones like start
this revolution of writing the show but
I think it was good that that we jumped
into that Elaine because then I feel
like I know a lot of other people got a
lot more confident in what they were
doing and put a lot more of themselves
into it which I think helped a lot of
things yeah um but yeah it's it's a lot
of nonsense it's a lot of nonsense but
and it's and it's literally exactly what
I wanted to be doing from the time I was
a little kid because my favorite
wrestler is a guy who went by the name
of flash funk he was also too cold
Scorpio in ECW he's like if you don't
know him
I know he's like 6-3 6-4 like he's a big
dude but uh Scorpio yeah too cold
Scorpio yeah um but he would come out
like dancing and stuff and we was in WWE
he had the funk edge so he was like I
don't know he dressed like listen for
like have a better time we dressed like
an 80s pimp and he was just dancing with
these girls and he'd come out when the
bell rang he could do all his crazy
acrobatic stuff like he could do like
front flips back flips hand Springs like
everything is like no you're way too big
to be doing this so for me he was like
the epitome of being able to like dance
and have fun and have everybody kind of
like oh cool here's a fun jovial guy
yeah and then when the bell rang look oh
well he's a serious wrestler because a
lot of times if you engage in the
dancing ridiculous stuff then people
can't take you seriously and it's a lot
harder for them to kind of be into your
matches because they know you was like
oh you're the funny guy you're the haha
guy here you're not going to win a match
but else I'll still kind of like you and
cheer for you a little bit when you come
out sort of walk that fine line like I
always loved that so that's kind of what
I'd always been searching for my whole
career because like I said another one
to be that super tough guy cuz that's
I'm I'm like five nine on a good day
like 205 like I'm I'm not a big person
I'm one of the smaller guys on the
sir and so I know that that's not the
role that I'm going to be able to play
on the show but in the role of new date
I can do exactly what I need to do and
be just as big personality wise as
anybody else on the show mm-hmm do you
feel like that separating you putting
yourself in a different Lane than some
of the other people has has given you
more success within the WWE or in your
career generally 100% 100% I feel like
it's like we're all trying to get to the
same place but let's say the 405 is
backed up yeah so I know back roads and
I'll get there a lot faster than you
guys you guys don't might make it but
it's gonna take you a lot longer and
you're gonna bit a much more stress on
your car yeah I'm gonna put more
emissions into the air she's bad for the
planet mm-hmm just find a new Lane find
a new Lane and get down there because
that's that's the whole goal is I would
say for a lot of us just trying to be
six as successful as possible in our
careers success looks different for a
lot of different people for me success
was or is just having a good time at
work having fun being able to have
people smile and be excited when it come
out for instance like we went to like we
go to like Japan we go to Germany just
went to Kauai Kuala Lumpur mm-hmm and
there were people there who were like oh
save your woods it's like why do you
know my name I said a random nerdy dude
from Georgia like you shouldn't know who
I am so it's a very like humbling thing
so even more top of that they're not
talking to me about wrestling they're
talking to me about video games yeah so
to me like that's that success being
able to surpass like the life goal that
I had of becoming a professional
wrestler on television - okay well I
also my goals were be a pro wrestler or
make video games and said okay well I'm
a pro wrestler and now I'm bleeding into
this video game world and not people are
more recognizing me as Austin Creed
because like the YouTube channel and
doing stuff like this like podcast going
to stuff like packs and like I go to
Dragon Con every year just due to
paternal cosplay stuff so people are
starting to see that side of me a lot
more and being able to relate to that
which then again can bring them to
wrestling if they don't like it already
so if there's someone listed into this
who doesn't necessarily watch WWE
anymore because they got made fun of in
high school so they quit watching it
whatever that stuff's for kids and
like oh people still watch wrestling
right here that so much because
wrestling yeah it's one of the largest
like things of a entertainment venues on
the planet and so I've got a lot of
people who are like oh you know I fell
off but I just I listen to on this
podcast and I didn't realize like that
wrestling had changed so much and
they've come back to wrestling and they
love it again and so it's very cool to
see that mixture because for me it's
just a Venn diagram of like gamers
wrestling fans and in the middle like
I'm trying to stretch that as much as
humanly possible because we're all the
same kind of nerd you know I mean we all
got made fun of and we're the ones who
like persevered through getting made fun
of and although the BS and now
everything that we like everyone on the
earth exists so cool and they want to be
a part of it it's like yeah you guys can
come in you know what you did to us but
you can still come in we have no hate
here but I just wanna bring the nerd
dumbs together that's very very noble so
I'm a huge like action movie buff I love
stunts especially like physical stunts
like old martial arts movies I love
Jackie Chan yeah classic Asian gently
Donnie Yen all this guy's um funny story
you and Sonia of Firefox were actually
hosting I think like the Video Game
Awards isn't like that yeah when we
debuted nerf John wick oh my god yes yes
I was in tears watching them oh my god
taking all the guns and the headshots
and stuff that's hilarious but you know
so I always this like fascination with
like the job of stunts and physical
acting and taking hits you know for
entertainment and that kind of stuff and
you know I want to ask you you know
wrestling's obviously super physical and
you know very can be very hard on your
body and like when you're when you're
doing a match you take a hard hit like
what what's the recovery like after that
like how do you how do you keep yourself
in shape and functioning and recover
from getting out there again that crap
kicked out of you ah you just you're
just gonna do it I've been wrestling I
think 15 years in September Wow
I think if my bats write 14 or 15 years
in September I started right out of high
school
but it's something like you have to be
like kind of I guess I'm
masochists to wonder because it doesn't
feel good hmm it does not feel good at
all but there's just something about
that like you said that physical
activity and doing that in front of
people a crowd that appreciates it and
being able to understand how to tell a
story through physicality and have
people understand it and go okay well
this is the bad guy this is the good guy
oh my god I want the good guy to win so
much like being able to evoke those
kinds of emotions that kind of keeps you
going because there have been times
where and we're not trying to like
obliterator out there because we're
doing this five sometimes like six
nights a week sometimes we're going to
overseas tours or were in the UK
bouncing around for two two and a half
weeks and we got shows every single day
we'll come right back to the states do
two more shows go home for two days and
we're right back out again because like
we were saying earlier that there's no
off season yeah so people say like oh
you know it's like a you know like
football or baseball about school like
well they and hats off to them because
it's not easy to do any type of physical
sport like that for a job like they have
the offseason to be able to recover
take this three months to like get
massages do your yoga stretching like
whatever it is to try to recoup your
body for the next season because you
have to prepare like we don't have that
like after our biggest show of the year
WrestleMania which you can catch on the
WWE Network for only $9.99 a month
that's free I believe you uh the night
after WrestleMania we have a show hmm
the night after yeah we have raw because
people come from literally all over the
world I think it something like 260
countries people come from to see
Wrestlemania and so they'll come in and
they come in for like a week because we
have access which is essentially like a
it's like a wrestling convention
essentially so we have that throughout
the whole week there's signings there's
like I think we might like a pancake
breakfast to dismiss WrestleMania the
people are there they come from Japan
Malaysia all over so they're they're
from like Thursday they go Thursday
Friday Saturday and also sorry when we
back up so whatever city Russell mania
is in tons of other wrestling
organizations will come and have shows
in that town because tons of wrestling
fans are there so like if your wrestling
fan
you go to that town because it's it's
wrestlers holiday you know what I mean
there's so much stuff to do and so
you'll be there Friday Saturday Sunday
is WrestleMania or sorry saturday is NXT
which is a huge show sunday is
WrestleMania which is like 7:00
hours now then Monday is raw then
Tuesday's Smackdown and then we go home
for two days and then we'll go out to do
shows like Friday and so it's just it's
a constant thing constant but to the to
the question of how to deal with being
hit you just kind do it and you might
come back like you might catch somebody
an accident a little more than you meant
to or you might be a little too fired up
but like if I if I actually pop to you
you pop me back and we're even but say
like I said where you leave like your
drama at the door so like if you and I
had a situation once we go through the
curtain we are professionals first and
foremost because I'm giving you my body
you're giving me your body any any beef
that we have completely squashed right
before we go out there because we know
it there's that what we're doing is
bigger than us bigger than whatever
issues we might have and like any other
job there's people you like people you
don't like people you hang out with
people you don't but we're all there for
one common goal and everyone puts that
above anything else
alright that's fascinating yeah yeah I
mean just like we went last year with
John Carly took us behind the scenes
Brian man at that point after I just I
just put a pin in the hole I just put a
pin in the whole situation I just said
WWE's the one of the one of the if not
the greatest moving shows traveling
shows on earth yeah on the planet yes
Barnum and Bailey isn't doing anything
you know I think we're the biggest yeah
yeah it's gotta be huh well this is a
good segue into your question was it
good segue into my next question which
is someone of your athleticism probably
could have done any sport I would well
thank you so you know the one thing
about wrestling is that it's not just an
athletic competition it's entertainment
and so in this entertaining side of it
you can't necessarily always choose your
own destiny as you could in a sport like
baseball or you know I guess you're
still on a team you know you're still
hinged to whatever the team does but but
that sense of athletic accomplishment
being directly tied to how successful
you are in the sport is not obviously
the same as other sports in the WWE so
have you felt I guess any have you
experienced that in any way and if so
you know what have you done or tried to
do to change that um so I guess I would
say that I felt that before we started
new day because like you said so in any
other sport it's like okay your success
is measured by like okay did you guys
win the Super Bowl
did you win the World Series and it's
different for us because it's um
essentially so talking about actual
movies like if I got a role to be Anna
Jackie Chan movie and I'm not the star
I'm like a bad guy a like I'm not mad
about that I'm stoked
yes I'm part of a Jackie Chan movie this
is dope so what's the same thing in WWE
you might not be the person who has the
ball right now but you are part of the
show to make sure that that person
becomes elevated enough so that we can
create stories we can create emotional
content for people that are watching
that so then when it is your turn if you
reach that level people will be there do
that for you but I guess I would say
that I felt that like I said before we
started a new day because I had been
with the company since 2010 and I was in
the developmental area and I wasn't on
the main roster yet it finally got to
the main roster wasn't really doing
anything and at this point I felt like
an item in wrestling long enough where I
trusted my instincts and I had been in
like a like mentally not in a good place
and so I was just kind of just
downtrodden just kind of complaining
about everything all the time and then
one of my friends I'll never forget this
he just told me he's like you know what
I'm I'm really tired of you complaining
about everything and I was like you know
what someone like is real with you you
kind of like get defensive for a second
and like what then he's like no listen
he's like you've been complaining about
the same stuff for like three years shut
up and do something about it
so that's when it kind of hit me like oh
I I should just quit quit whining and
actually like make a move rather than
kind of waiting for things to happen to
say rather than saying like hey hello I
have arrived for work I would like to do
a good job please like
kick in the door and say this is what I
want to do if you don't want to do that
then I'll roll so it's kind of a thing
of like betting on yourself so that's
when I approached Ian Kofi was like hey
I got this idea I want to do this Kofi
obviously already established one of the
most decorated humans to ever come
through WVUE II had just come off being
I think Intercontinental Champion and I
hadn't done anything but got beat up by
a ton of people I did a few months and
so my thought was I decided for this
group I want to try it out if it doesn't
work and it just fails like that's on me
and I shouldn't be here because my idea
didn't work because that would prove to
me that I don't know what I'm doing and
I should be doing something else I
should go and use my degree I should
start working with some psychologists
and just talk to people about their
problems and then and then luckily it
worked out and when we when they let us
make the group we were we were good guys
for the industry terms we were baby
faces and we thought we should be bad
guys heals and so um after a while some
things happened in people were training
like new day sucks and it's like okay
yes cool they'll let us like turn a
corner and we can be bad guys now and
they thought that since Kofi had been a
babyface for so long that they wouldn't
boo him and so to me I was like no like
we're in control of that like I
guarantee you went to missing man and I
was like if if you give us forgive me a
microphone four weeks in a row I
guarantee you that they'll boo Kofi
Kingston and he was like you really
believe in this that much I said yes I
believe that I can do it and um and he
goes for weeks and if you don't do it in
four weeks what happens I said if I
don't do it in four weeks
you've got 60 dudes and developmental
that deserve this spot more than I do
like so I could send you home and get
ready you guys like then yeah I think
you should if I can't do it if I can't
make good on this then I don't deserve
to be here he's like all right always
takes yeah well I got at that point I
feel like I had done everything that I
could do and I still wasn't I wasn't
getting opportunities on TV I was like
oh well you know I know how to wrestle
like I've got like crazy hair like my
gear is really cool like I've done
everything like that quote unquote
you're like supposed to do but you
realized that do
we're supposed to do only get you so far
you you can't go down swinging somebody
else's punches you have to swing your
own punches so like if it wouldn't have
worked I wouldn't be one of the people
who whether you get fired from any job
you know you hear some people get fired
and they just complain about the job and
it's like sometimes like when his
personal responsibilities come into play
like what did you do to not advance
yourself enough that's a super powerful
mindset to have yeah I feel like it and
like I said it took me a long time to
get there and it was until my friend
kind of kicked me in the face and told
me that and so so it's like finally did
everything and and like it at week three
they booed Kofi a little bit and after
that we were cool like they told us okay
cool week oh you guys are bad guys now
and we just ran with it and luckily it
worked
it was just like like you said it was
the the ridiculous nut level the
ridiculousness level was at an all-time
high
yeah because we were just trying to go
for like shock and awe and trying to see
we can get away with and that's when we
like a quieter trombone and it was just
like what what is happening right now
and like I said we wanted to be a fever
dream and so luckily we we got the
opportunity to do that but it was
because we we quit complaining and just
took a risk because like I said if we
would have swung this punch and got
completely knocked out that's like okay
that's on me I now know that I'm meant
to do something else but I think that
sometimes a lot of times most of the
time we as humans are it's a scary thing
to do
yeah it's a leap of faith and I think
though it's harder to take a leap of
faith in yourself than it is in
something or someone else sometimes yeah
because you realize you you're the only
one who can who can own that you know
for the rest of your life like this
happened because I made this choice and
so you have to become okay with that
before you're able to take that jump
yeah take no responsibility on yourself
is scary and that's you see a lot of
people like in jobs they have shared
responsibility so they'll have to take
responsibility for failure but it also
means that if you take responsibility
for yourself you take responsibility and
your success and which is great and this
might be a little assumptive um on my
part but I'm gonna assume anyways let's
go when was the point where you're like
I made it hmm so I'm assuming that
you've hit that point and I think it's
kind of fair to assume that
certain degree but where did that switch
flip um it's weird cuz that that gauge
moves it moves around so once once a new
day once we had won the Tag Titles it
was like okay cool
I think like we've we've we've
accomplished like one of the things that
we wanted to do but it's like I think
you have to we're in that mindset of you
have your this goal for ya here's the
switch that you flip like okay we made
it but then as soon as you get there
it's like we want something else yeah
there's like never satisfied and I think
that's what helps us continuously keep
grinding and trying to think of new
stuff but like the first time I guess
would feel that is probably probably
when we won the titles for the first
time at SummerSlam but then we we were
lucky enough to hold the titles for 483
days longest ever yeah and so that's
that's not something that you think of
as I keep you like oh I want to be the
longest reigning tag team champion in
the history of the company it's like no
your goal is like I want to be a said
just like this I want to be a TV
wrestler yeah and so like even even just
getting the contract for the first time
I was like okay made it mmm and then
you're in there for like two three
months look okay I didn't make it yet
yes and then I think like I said it
keeps moving so even even when we hit
that it was okay we made it and then at
the same time I was like but my youtube
channel needs more subscribers and then
it turned into like so for me my my goal
for like making it now is like I'm
saying Erlich bridging that gap between
wrestling fans and video game fans and
literally just I want the world's to be
so intertwined that they're one in the
same
yeah cuz we like video games because of
storytelling because of the love and the
hard work people put into these games
and it's the same exact thing for
wrestling and so once once that happens
then I'll say yes I've made it are you
great answer that's a great night how
you doing
it was a good answer
so you said you're developing games
trying to trying to trying to so where's
it's it's very much in the process of
infancy right now so currently uh
looking for the right couple of
developers and also since I don't do
that I don't know exactly what I need
yeah we're just kind of talking to
random people about it so if you're
listening to this and you want to make
sweet mobile games with me let me know
at Xavier woods PhD in your mind's eye
where to where did I say you have a PhD
no so okay that's a long story
yeah I didn't mean to cut you off I just
have to throw that out there it's okay
do you want to me to answer this one
first or answer this and come back to
this whatever you want to do okay I'll
handle this one first okay
so almost had a PhD so I've got two
undergraduates a masters and I was at
the dissertation phase for my PhD and so
I was the same spot in the dissertation
for like two years and all my previous
professors I was sending them my stuff
and they're like why is this not going
through like this experiment like works
like you should be done with this by now
like yes I know
and so then the school that I was
attending which will remain unnamed
because I cannot stand them this was
educational psychology educational
psychology yes we found out they were
just holding students at bets at that
one spot because it was like X amount of
dollars every three months to continue
in that process
oh and so they would like pass a few
people so they'd say like oh you know
here's our certified PhDs but then the
other like 300 of us we all like got
together and like what is happening and
we found out they were just doing it to
like raking money hmm and so there was
like a big hoopla about it and a bunch
of us ended up leaving the school so
when I went to transfer the the new
administrators for the new school that I
was going to go to but like okay so you
can only test out of like two or three
classes and then in order to get the
degree from us you have to have the
majority of your credits from us so
it'll be another three and a half years
and like you know everything already so
it's literally if you can give us this
money and we can give you the piece of
paper in three and a half years or you
can just be content with the fact that
you like have the knowledge already and
at that point like wrestling had kicked
off like new date kicked off like the
YouTube channel is kicking off so you're
a wrestling doing all this yeah how did
you find how do you find the time
that's crazy
so so I started wrestling right out of
high school and then did all throughout
college so I went to firmer in
University in South Carolina and I would
at the time I didn't have a car at
school so on Friday nights I would
borrow one of my friends cars and I
would drive to wherever in the Carolinas
I had to wrestle so kind of just like
getting my name out there and everything
so by sophomore year I was wrestling
five nights a week and we did school
Monday through Friday so it was school
every day there was a place near our
school where I'd wrestled Tuesday night
right after class Friday I would drive
to wherever in the Carolinas Friday
Saturday Russell's Sunday morning Sunday
night go back to school Sunday night for
a class on Monday morning you must not
sleep no so my favorite quote right now
is sleep is the cousin of death and I
don't like that family so this is it's
just kind of what I've my parents told
me if there's some that you want to do
it's not a sense of if you have the time
it's if you want to do it you'll make
the time and so I liken that to I want
to learn Japanese and I've one-to-one
Japanese since I was a little kid and my
mom for Christmas like eight years in a
row got me like how to speak Japanese
CDs how to speak Japanese books man your
weed levels are like so much higher than
now so from the time I was a little kid
to now I'm 32 years old I know like two
words of Japanese Oh congratulations
thank you thank you very much so tell
Artie got to that point me saying I want
to learn Japanese but not putting in any
work to learn it I have to come to terms
with
oh I don't actually want to learn
Japanese I like the idea of possibly
knowing Japanese so it's like when
you're again when you're real with
yourself about stuff and you go okay I
don't actually want this but like
wrestling is something that I actually
wanted so rather than joining a
fraternity rather than being there for
parties rather than having that full
like quote/unquote college experience
there's like no I have other stuff to do
I'm here to get an education and I want
to have a contract wrestling on TV
before I graduate like that was the goal
and I got lucky enough to get one with
organization ta like since once before I
graduated
and it's funny because my I told my dad
I called most like I got a I got a deal
with Tina he's like wait what I was like
yes I did it he was like are you kidding
me like we're gonna do a school like
yeah yeah I'm gonna finish this was the
goal so ha ha ha ha my best friend so uh
we we dated in high school and first
time I met her dad he looks at me and he
goes uh so what do you plan to do with
your life sir I want to be a pro
wrestler oh okay yeah yeah what do you
want you to make money it was like okay
all right sweet so look we're real good
friends and everything and so I saw him
I had gone home looks like a Christmas
break after I got in the contract and I
saw him I like Publix or supermarket and
Miguel he hasn't gone we're catching up
everything because also were you up to
no I said it's funny you should ask
well I actually got a contract to
wrestle on TV and he goes well I'll go
home and eat my shoes but yes I'll just
did it all throughout college got that
deal wrestle around for a bit um did my
masters was with with TNA and then got
signed to WWE did my Master's finished
up my master's ball with David it was a
while while I was with WWE started my
ph.d program all the BS stuff happened
but uh yeah I it's it's weird because as
much as we do travel we don't have a lot
of time at home but when you start
finding other things that you want to
pursue you find out that you you do have
the time it's figuring how to make it so
like I've got I have a kid at home
really he's almost 2 so like figuring
how to juggle that with like okay so I
want to increase output on the YouTube
channel and I want to do this and I got
a workout and I'm gonna travel and then
I got to come home and then I there's a
baby at the house but I have to go and
try to I have to make an attempt to be
like super dad because I'm not there a
lot but again it's like it's figuring
out how to do it so it's like okay so on
Monday night after the show I'll make
sure that I try to get a bunch of sleep
so that day I'll be effective for
Smackdown and I can try to get a bunch
of sleep again so then when I get home
on Wednesday
I can like hang out with him and then
tried not sleep and then catch up on
like filming stuff so he goes to bed
then I'll go downstairs to the basement
to my set up and film for youtuber get
on Twitch get up early do stuff with him
like trying to find times to sleep that
don't interfere with the stuff that
we're trying to try to do in life mm-hmm
which is probably not healthy but it's
it's fine
have you tried like the the power
sleeping method where you you're awake
for four hours you sleep for 20 minutes
and you're awake far as you sleep we're
talking oh I can't do it no that's all
unique oh I try I can't do that I try
I'm not I'm not mentally strong enough
that's off to you I already tried to do
it it lasted like a week no I just need
a solid eight hours it's like imagine
hanging out there friends man sorry guys
I have to go take a nap I do want to
sleep on airplanes so like I was saying
earlier today that flight from Atlanta
to here out the whole time and now I
feel I feel great
what's in your airplane survival kit ooh
so I have a he's got it right here Oh
God this is this is my airplane survival
kit and as you see this is my very dirty
string backpack sarin this is from
Kuroko's no basketball one of my
favorite animes
so in my ear Penn's arrival kit I have
my switch nice are you big in this match
right now
uh yes but I'm also big into Wheel of
Fortune will you love fortune on the
switch yes it's a double package wheel
of fortune and jeopardy Wow and so the
goal for 2019 is to me the guys talking
about Tyler breeze and there's a girl
Selena Vega so like we we have a really
good rapport and we play with a fortune
every once in a while and so our goal is
to get on wheel of fortune this year
because when you watch wheel of fortune
it's never going off the air Pat Sajak
is a total total G and he's just the man
and killing the show but you you have
like the same kind of people on it all
the time
but if we can get on there and just
scream and yell at each other that's all
I want
so you heard it here fortune 2019 boom I
didn't know you could play jeopardy on
there that sounds like I might need to
get a switch now oh yeah oh yeah switch
wallet
uh right now see ice it's a condensed
version because I was coming here I'm
done my sunglasses oh cool um the switch
and gum that's it this is my my survival
pack it's a solid survival pack got to
as long as the switches and then you're
pretty much good pretty much because you
can just walk through the airport and
someone will be playing the switch
somewhere and like a like you said are
you playing smash ok dope come get this
Kirby work I'm gonna challenge you to a
game after we're all done here
perfect alright perfect cause he's the
only one I know to play you but you main
Kirby huh yeah because of the whatsit
the adventure mode oh yeah I was in
spirits meld yeah so cuz I never played
any other smashes I got playing for a
little bit but I never got into him I
like watching people play him because I
watching be someone who's good with ice
climbers just like this is great because
there's everyone else is just infuriated
but yeah for this one I was like okay
let me actually sit down and like take
the time and try to figure out I play it
so like it's I'm not great but I'm okay
I'm okay enough all right Clint will
just beat all of us it doesn't matter
Jake I'm sorry to cut off your question
I mean I'm not even gonna ask my
original question now because of oh I'm
sorry I'm gonna actually I'm gonna ask
what it was like getting your first
wrestling gig I mean you touched on it a
little bit but like I've literally if
somebody asked me go out tomorrow get a
wrestling game I gotta work on these
probably you know I need to cut cut
something about my shirt because I can't
just go in there with like where do you
start do you want to be a wrestler where
do you start
so you find a wrestling school okay and
so at the time I was going to these
wrestling shows like once a month they
would do shows near my house my mom
calls me and she goes Austin there's
wrestlers at Walmart like what's or like
kicked up out of the bed and I was at my
buddy's house and we jumped in the car
drove over there and there's these two
guys sitting there and they're like yeah
we're having a we have this thing called
us play it's like a like a Dave &
Buster's II type place oh yeah oh yeah
we're having a show at the u.s. play
across the street and looking to be a
hardcore match to bring whatever weapons
you bought it was like oh
oh so I didn't know about independent
wrestling at that point in my life I
just knew WWE and WWF and ECW I didn't
know that there was like any other like
I had no clue how to get into it yeah so
anyway I'm going to these shows the
first time we go
and they said bring a weapon all we have
in the trunk we had a baseball bat for
some reason wooden baseball Bend so yeah
like a horse yeah so we brought that in
and we gave like throw to them during
the match and afterwards like state
afterwards and that all the guys signed
it for me and everything and go to these
every every single month and I wasn't
banned and so we had some concert or
something and so I showed her to the
show late so I pulled up on like speed
there I pulled in the parking spot I'm
in my like tuxedo with like my
cumberbund and bow tie it stuff and I
like bust into the room and it's just
sometimes like the main event and like
the the heel the bad guy like looks and
he like goes like this cuz he seasoned
my hand I've got the bat and this is
like it's like a like weird movie
situation like got close to nothing like
threw the bat like a javelin and he
caught it and sort of beating up the
good guy now screaming oh no the
Batman's here everyone just booing him
and me and I'm just like yes in this
cumberbund in bow ties 16 years old like
yeah so um you see were in the show no
no just a van but like I was there every
month and I'd always bring this bat okay
so like they would always eat him so
like he knew like oh this kid will
probably play around yeah like I toss
him the bat and he's like haha just
beating him with it and that's - it's
like a perfect spiral yeah that's like a
perfect javelin spot 100% was definitely
hundred percent so after that show the
guy who was in charge of the
organization came out to me and he was
like um you seem like you want to do
this and I was like I very much when I
do this sir please PLEASE he goes well
I'm starting to school in the next few
months here's my information if you want
to try it out give me a call and so long
story short go up there train and he is
his name's Rob Adonis one of the nicest
humans I've ever met he was like he's my
wrestling dad and so he taught me how to
talk to wrestling promoters how to get
booked on shows he taught me always have
your wrestling notebook with you so any
idea that you have you will forget it if
you don't write it down so I have a book
I started in I don't I'm horrible time
in years so whatever whatever years our
training so yeah so I have that book
still it's in my wrestling bag and I
write in it fully like I wrote in all
the way through and now it's flipped
upside down I'm writing in it backwards
but it's got like every wrestling idea
ever had any idea for like moves for
gear like my first set of gear is drawn
out in there and so I can go back and
see that stuff but uh yeah you just
learn how to essentially you learn how
to not die wrestling but like not break
people apart and then you kind of go out
into the wrestling world and he was
taught me like when you go to a show go
to it for the first time without talking
anybody without talking to the promoter
without talking any other wrestlers just
go and watch it
and just see what the shows like and see
what you would want to do see where you
might fit in the show see who you might
want to wrestle on the show afterwards
go in the back and talk to their
promoter and say hey you know what I
wrestle I'm from blah blah blah blah
blah I train with this guy that guy mom
and see if they'll let you and be on the
show the next week and so that's that's
what I did I would like I said when I
would leave school I would find a show
on the Internet I'd look something up
and at that point we had no GPS we said
like MapQuest so I print out the
MapQuest directions chorus drive to
wherever I was going happy by myself to
sitting in the corner watching wrestling
shows it like 17 years old like oh that
guy looks good I want to wrestle him all
man I want that guy and then I just go
talk to everybody and just try to learn
everything I could and so so I was
wrestling in North Georgia and the
Carolina and South Carolina and so what
happens is you find your places that
you're wrestling you try to become like
known there and then you go one town
over you become known there then you go
one more town over and you become known
there and you're trying to just expand
your your name and your reach until
finally okay you feel like you've done
enough stuff where you start sending
your stuff to like places in New York
places in Wyoming places in California
here you want to go to Mexico send
something down there resume is CDs with
your matches on it's something and it's
legit just like any other job you should
send out a resume and and then hopefully
you just get to keep bouncing around
that people know you in enough places
and then you create enough buzz and then
a larger company goes hey we want you to
work for us and so I was lucky enough to
to get that to happen Wow Wow so it's
it's a little bit like I mean I guess
there's a little bit of that in music
there's a little bit of that in martial
arts mm-hmm you know just this yeah this
I guess the grassroots nests of it yeah
yeah that's nice I think maybe that
insulates a little bit of the creativity
too from from like being prey corporate
prey yeah you know okay you can come up
you can you can develop relationships
with people in the sport on your own
yeah naturally you can come up with
person that personas naturally mm-hmm
that's cool I didn't I didn't know that
yeah it's a like you said so it's it's
the fully created by you you're you're
you're the talent
you are the marketer you are the social
media director you are the PR agent like
you're you're everything for yourself at
that point and then hopefully you get to
a point where you are part of like a
larger business and you can kind of like
shed some of those things and spend your
time doing working more directly just on
the creative they look on the creative
stuff so then more of your energy you
can go there but but yeah it is it's
definitely a grind and a hustle so very
have very similar to music very similar
to something like like boxing yeah your
fear you're in these smaller arenas so
for us we wrestled like VFW halls like
those were like veteran halls so or like
high school gyms I've ever stood on a
baseball field before like a like a
Little League baseball field you know
it's like anywhere I've wrestled in
strip clubs to the point where so I was
I was 18 and the guy running the show he
got me from the locker room put his
hands over my eyes and walked me to the
ring he's like I'm like get in trouble
for heaven and I've been on 21 year old
patient in here wrestle would get out
okay in the morning that's so wholesome
Yeah right
guess you were right use Russell
wherever you can trying to trying to
create a name for yourself trying to
create a buzz trying to learn so it's a
it's it's it's a grind
how long have you been doing your game
show for up up down down ah I'm bad with
time but I think it'll be by this III
it'll be four years so III is like our
birthday that was our launch and that
was very uh specifically planned so then
I could always get off to go to ether
but yeah we've been doing that for for
that long and met a ton of awesome
people along the way it got to do a
bunch of cool stuff and the fun part
about it for me is like learning how to
do things so learning like what
microphones are good learning about like
XLR stuff and learning about shotgun
microphones and then omnidirectional
microphones and cameras and all this
blip cam is good oh and I've got a can
and a TD to film I like a
video-on-demand stuff like I like
learning all that stuff because for me
learning things is where I feel like I'm
like I'm growing you know what I mean
and so like I said before doing stuff on
Twitch now now I'm learning twitch so
last night I just found out that you
could put a Spotify panel so that people
that are watching you on Twitch know
what like your recently Spotify music
isn't like oh that's really cool and so
um it's just I love all the gaming stuff
because there's so many facets of it
that I don't yet know about like the
streaming and about the YouTube aspect
of it that like I'm still I'm constantly
learning new stuff and that's like
probably the most fun thing about it for
me okay that's cool
you mentioned so you have that backpack
from an anime and you watch a lot of
anime I do I do
I I haven't been able to watch as much
as I would like to recently so like I
what got me back into it I was in a rut
and then I got deep into I started
watching YuYu Hakusho okay because
that's my favorite anime of all time I
think it's the most perfectly crafted
and well ended anime so when they're
like oh we're making new episodes of you
hakusho I was like I'm at the same time
so I was reading back into that and then
I saw uh what is it uh Prince of tennis
okay have you seen that mm-hmm so it's
just like I had four I'm not big into
sports at all
but for some reason sports animes really
gets me because then they're like oh
he's got the snake attack and it's like
they're explaining the technicalities
how this could happen in real life but
they're turning him into a snake and
he's like I'm doing weird stuff and so I
got deep into that and like okay I need
to get back on my anime grand so I got
into that which got me eventually into
what I really loved a Kuroko's no
basketball so if you don't know that
anime
Kuroko is such a non personality he's
like so boring that they forget he's on
the court he's really good at passing
and so like that's totally of my Alex
I'm like I'm a huge psychic guy like a
Crillon 'he's my dude tails is my guy
karoku is the ultimate sidekick to me
cuz so he's paired with the guy in the
teen movie he's got he's big he's strong
he's fast he can dunk and so his whole
thing he's like you're the light and I'm
the shadow the brighter you shine the
bigger I am and I was like it's so like
that kind of stuff sticks with me a lot
um is there a wrestling anime yes what
is it what is it called it's gonna
bother me I can't remember but yes and
it's really good but it's based in the
so are there's another company wrestling
company called New Japan and so it's
based with those characters and I'm just
like super incredibly jealous that I
wasn't able to be a part of it cuz it's
not my wrestling company it's like
really good that's cool I just finished
my hero academia Hulu nice right
I gotta watch season 3 stole she didn't
threes good I know a shame did he watch
the new attack on Titan season no so I
got half with you season 2 season two's
not good yeah season 3 is it was like it
was hard to get through yeah and I like
season 1 so much you see someone's like
my opinion the best one of the best
anime it's incredibly resistant sever
made incredible just that first thing
we're at the end of first episode when
you see the thing eat his mom yeah what
is this is incredible I love this yeah
why well season like so yeah its season
2 of attack on Titan that we're sorry
Jake we're just going to do
in season two was kind of like this like
little filler season to buy them time
for season three okay
in season three is excellent like every
episode something's happening and like I
never got into the show lost because I
knew that I just getting [ __ ] around
the whole time yeah some people loved it
I didn't yeah and I was worried that
that was happening with attack on Titan
like they're just throwing all this
mystery yeah yeah no every single thing
there's an answer to every single place
out in a great way and just yeah so
season 3 is worth checking out okay I'll
take it I got a itíd up back any gigs
like these into I was watching and it's
like it's one it seems like you don't
want to say like I don't know if I like
listening yeah cuz it's so good but yeah
I just kind of fell off there watching
Food Wars and horses that might be that
might be a perfect yet it man it's so
good check it out you all we haven't
seen it no it's okay so uh cut this out
if you need to but I'll just say it so
it's essentially an anime about people
it's like it's Iron Chef the anime okay
but people can cook so well that
essentially when you eat their food you
come that's essentially the anime and
they want you what you see it you'll get
it
and there's something all the foods like
a lovingly like rendered oh yeah yeah
like I don't I don't like most food but
I want to eat everything that they make
on this with like Japanese culture and
like drawing painting or sculpting food
I don't know but it's great like Final
Fantasy 15 oh good yeah I would cook
just to see the the meals felt like half
the graphics budget I'm just like yeah
so so food was really good another one
I'm really into is case closed
hmm so it's uh it's like a it's like Law
& Order the anime but this guy he was
really good it was a really good high
school detective
he got shot with this dart and it turned
him into a little kid it's so but like
30 seasons he's still a little kid but
he's his amazing detective and it's just
like something some of our two parts
will they like go to like a party
somebody dies and they gotta figure out
everything by the end of it they
explained everything that happened here
like
they're so smart good so I love a good
murder mystery huh let's check it out
hey sing devil man crybaby I'm nuts no
I'd hurry to watch it I didn't think
that it was a real thing because of the
name yeah it's the real thing I was like
double-double man crybaby does not sound
real now it's cuz he's always he's
always crying because he's committing so
much violence dude but he has to he has
to murder and he just he just he cries
because of Buddy Pino
she's beautiful demons he's killing but
he has to do it because we've seen the
one I cannot remember the name of it but
I saw like an ad for it but it looks it
was like a 45-second like ad and it
looked like it's high school kids
playing some sort of game where you put
your finger in a guillotine and it's
like a Russian Roulette but with a
guillotine so if you get chopped you
lose a finger
oh wow it looked awesome I'm very much
in the dark animes yeah so then you're
gonna like devil man crime okay okay
yeah is it like a um what is it uh it's
the one where you write the names in the
book Oh death no death no yeah kinda
it's basically the premise behind devil
man cry baby is that there's demons
living among us like hidden s people and
this this demon infects this guy he's
just like I needed some sweet kid and he
needs effective this demon for some
reason he can control the demon so ours
everybody else I gonna get infected the
demon do they become the demon he ends
up being able to harnesses Stephens
powers and he's basically be like it's
his mission to kill all the other
Diesel's he has to do it becomes a
really well executed like piece on like
intolerance and like learning to
communicate with other people over
disagreements rather than just like
killing everybody yeah but like the
animation style is crazy they have this
everything's always set like this weird
like driving like house techno beat like
when anything's getting really bloody
and violent it's just like in the
background and it's like this weird
great pairing that you know you get with
the music and the animation but yeah
it's uh it's all small those things were
at like there's like ten or twelve
episodes
just a quick side tangent I was watching
this on the airplane when I was coming
back from my honeymoon with me my wife
there's lots of boobs and lots of blood
and like we're seeing that we have to
like hide my iPad so that actually that
got me so okay I was big into Jackie
Chan movies when we go to Blockbuster so
the way that our blockbuster set up when
like the martial arts movies ended anime
started mm-hmm that's how I got Anna
Anna makes I finished watching all those
movies and the first thing was Akira Oh
walked a little too far down the aisle
yeah due to curious what a good like
starting incredibly like for like an 11
year old and that was the first time
like would he saw like boobs drawn as a
girl I then just go oh my god just yeah
when you and the person walks in to talk
to the guy and he's busy yeah I'm
watching that as like a literally like
what is happening this is why can just
watch this like my parents like they
didn't know yeah always watching
Japanese cartoons but uh yeah Akira
Akira is what really hooked me in I got
a Mike Nate a styled one wheel I did a I
did I have a one wheel and I stylist
I'll I still like Anita's motorcycle did
all the replicated all the pretty uh
stickers and everything put them on the
top
yeah he's I need to see this once the
podcast yes okay sorry
just to sell random stray so you talked
about that being on the airplane
watching it so do you guys watch Steven
universe mm-hmm okay
so Steven universe is is yeah I'll say
it Steven universe might be the not
might Steven universe is the greatest
animated show of all time I would say
that I will say that okay I know hot
take take thank you and I say that
because whether you are a child a
teenager or an adult Steven universe
will hit you somewhere and it will hit
very hard mm-hmm so it's a story of this
kid and he lives with these like three
like alien women essentially and his mom
is gone his dad still around his dad is
a human I don't wanna spoil ya let me
say okay so he's finding things out
about his mom as you go along but he's a
little kid he's like eight or nine I
think and um as he's finding things out
you you as an adult watching this
realize oh my god he doesn't have the
chance to actually be with his mom but
he finds these things about himself and
his mother and his mother's friends and
about his dad through these things that
his mom left him that will become so
important to him why he moves into
adulthood so like that hits you as an
adult but as a kid you're watching these
things and you're learning these lessons
cuz remember how like duck tales and
stuff Darkwing Duck it's the only show
that talked to you how to be how to
manage time and while being a superhero
and a single dad what like that how do
you hold a job and be a single dad as a
kid you watch that you say oh he's
really stressed but he's trying his best
I was a kid you go Oh dad's really
stressed but he's trying his best as an
adult you go oh this is what the kid is
feeling so like you're getting something
out of it Steven universe is the same
thing for kids all the way up to adults
but to get to the point I was watching
an episode on on the plane and I'm
sitting there with my phone when I got
my headphones in and there's an episode
where he he obtains like this video of
his mom and she's talking to him giving
him like this very like heartfelt
message and the way that's written it's
not written like to make you feel these
emotions or to make you cry it's just
written in like a real way and so I'm
watching this and I am I'm losing it
like I'm not like quick like a little
bit I'm crying loud and so the woman
next to me she taps me she goes are you
ahead it's like my phones kind of turned
every you can see it sorry are you okay
and her daughter I don't know how old
she was it may be early teens
she was mom he's watching Steven
universe you wouldn't get it
god it's so good it's so good man that
girl saved you all 100% I don't have to
check it out now you got me hooked by if
there's anything that I recommend it's
Steven universe like I I cried when I
met the woman who made it oh because I
wasn't ready to meet her I turned on she
was right there and instantly I start
crying she let the embodiment and she
get her with adventure time yeah I think
so yeah yeah yeah just just very good
just oh just a good like people with
good hearts it makes me feel good about
stuff yeah that's good what usually
happens like this okay
let's I got a I got a rounding a
rounding out question here okay um so
you were you're a professional wrestler
you're can I call you a professional
gamer oh you do anything video games I
do send your profession yes but okay you
have a successful YouTube channel where
part of what you do is play games yeah I
I exited name for this I want to be like
the video game promoter hmm that's
first-ever
yeah yeah yeah there we go so that's
what that leads into my question I mean
what it seems like you know you growing
up you had these two childhood dreams
video games wrestling you made time for
them you put the work into them you
contributed something new to the sport
that you're in to get to where you are
so what's next for you what are you in
an ideal universe what what would you
like to do next so if like I've talked
about this and I can't fully talk about
it because it's like hopefully coming to
fruition at some point we're in the
creating a hitch phase okay there is a
TV show
that were trying to create that would be
very beneficial for people who enjoy
video games hmm I can't really talk
about it because if I do someone will
with more means will steal the idea and
then I'll have to go to jail all right
that's that's what's next a a video game
related television show that will
hopefully be on a cool network that'd be
cool and that's that's what I will say
about that that's awesome all right all
right these slide looks happening like
do you have anything else Niko that you
wanna that you want to jump on here yeah
I just want to jump on the fact that we
never said one punch man was really good
and talking about a no yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that season tears coming out in like two
months what really got me about that was
that last fight cuz like even though
he's like fighting you still like it's
the same thing like you think oh man
he's met his match like no one punch one
punch man at some point I mean it's been
an honor having you on thanks for for
coming on the show and inspiration to
many so keep doing it and keep keep
doing the good work man I can't wait to
see what you do next I'm gonna try we'll
see you we'll see if anything I'm very
confident that things will be well
you I appreciate it guys thank you for
having me of course
and just wanna remind people up up down
down on youtube check out Austin's
gaming channel mhm
and your twitch is twitch.tv slash
Austin Creed there is if you want to
check me up on Instagram and Twitter at
Xavier woods PhD do that follow me on
all social media accounts follow me on
all accounts do it do it now subscribe
to our channel too please yes subscribe
remember this and you meet more sweet
people
well I only I say more that's if you
thought I was a sweet person you'll meet
sweet people not me if you didn't think
I was sweet thank you for listening
just watching Steven universe you guys
wouldn't get it yeah
all right thanks man thank you once
again huge thanks to Austin for coming
out on the corridor cast if you guys
haven't seen him on Smackdown I would
definitely recommend it also on YouTube
add up up down down or on Twitch so just
huge thanks what a great dude and had a
ton of fun talking to him again if you
guys aren't subscribed to the corridor
cast I would highly recommend it we
release these episodes every week and
they are free and they always will be